when did you first start uh
getting tattoo in your face in your head
man because
some of these tattoos do some of them
look very very old right i i um was
when i first got i had got a f-13 on my
chin when i was like right before i went
to juvenile hall i was about 13 years
old i put a f-13 with an la on top of my
chin
um i had that i was i went to that
before i started tattooing like my whole
body like i still had some tats on my
body but
i went to the face like right away and
my
my grandma she was like oh she seemed
that when i was younger i used to go
stop by this this jewelry store and
always look at this chain that i liked
you know i would just go look at it ask
him to try it on i didn't have no money
but i would still go look at it and let
me see that chain and try it on and
they'll put it back they knew damn well
that ain't no money they're like he just
here looking at that damn chain so she
came up one day and told me look if you
take off that tattoo on your chin i'll
get you that chain so i was like all
right but i still didn't even think
about it until you know being in the
system
um before i got i came home one of the
times i had a court order for them to
take it off and i had to go through
homeboys industry to where they were
gonna
excuse me erase well you know to the
laser technology yeah and
you know i reached out to my grandma and
i told her hey i'm gonna take it off
then so i could get that chain but i
really had to take it off like you know
so she bought me the chain
i got the laser tattoo removal
and then i started getting more tattoos
on my face and then she was like you
worked me basically like
she's like i told her i you told me just
to take off that tattoo you didn't say i
couldn't get a new one because i can't
get some more so
you know it turned out like that after
that she was just like she wasn't
trusting me no more when it came to that
[ __ ] you know she's like nah but yeah
like um i started young with the tattoos
on my face 13 14 years old
was there uh i mean when you have
tattoos like you have i'm assuming that
there's some that you regret is there
any tattoo that comes to mind that you
regret more than others
maybe like female names and [ __ ] over
the years being young and dumb and
you know what i'm saying in the heat of
the moment what are you like go get your
name tattoo tomorrow
right you know like but now it's like
i just i just plaster over those
[ __ ] now like you know
ain't no biggie i feel like what's dope
about like your your appearance is
first of all it people are intrigued i
think when they see you right they're
like yo who's that right like who's the
guy and then they hear the music they're
like oh [ __ ] right
and then i also feel like you could
[ __ ] be in any [ __ ] movie like so
many people have been telling me bro
you're missing out on all kinds of
acting bread like i started to have when
i first came home from prison i started
doing the whole um
what was that i mean you're going to get
typecasted right no yeah you're gonna be
you're gonna be like the big homie in
the hood or yeah yeah they're always
gonna choose me for certain certain
roles for sure but [ __ ] though all my
the money's green when i first came home
it's like i didn't have a car so it was
hard for me to get from point a to point
b i was sharing with the girl that i was
with at the time but she also had to
work
so it was like some days i couldn't make
it sometimes i could so i think the
central casting kind of got tired of me
pulling up late or not oh okay so that
so you just you would have hard times
getting the likes right locations and
stuff like well now it's different you
know i got my own stuff and it's like a
lot easier but
maybe i would have to reapply or
something you know what i mean but yeah
man i just seen recently that uh a lot
of people started tagging me to uh this
uh
all hell the king i guess it's a disney
movie that i came out in so they're like
damn you're in the disney movie what the
[ __ ] like you know people tagging me oh
[ __ ] i didn't know and we did that like
six years seven years wow
and then obviously ballet originals
thing was dope oh shout out
cartoon like that was a dope they
definitely made that happen bro you know
i was appreciative 100 percent